Immer mal wieder gibt es schlagzeilen zu
tutanchamuns grab und das wäre wohl die entdeckung des jahrhunderts ein forschungsteam aus italien hat hinweise darauf gefunden dass
direkt neben
tutanchamuns grab eine oder sogar mehrere bislang unbekannte
grabkammern existieren könnten frühere untersuchungen hatten darin sogar die mumie seiner stiefmutter
Nofretete vermutet wow wie konkret die aktuellen forschungsergebnisse wirklich sind und ob sie das rätsel
Um die grabkammer, des großen ägyptischen pharaos jetzt lüften jetzt index. Um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Schon seit
3400 jahren ist der pharao tutanchamun tod und unter der erde vergraben seiner grabstätte wurde noch seit
22 entdeckt und obwohl das schon so lange her ist ist das tal der könige immer mal wieder eine schlagzeile wert zuletzt noch
Im sommer 2015 als ein britischer archäologe verkündete das ist hinter einer glaswand
des pharaos weitere räume gelbe linien strukturen name als hinweise und auf den aufnahmen der nördlichen und westlichen
kann
Warnt der grabkammer wollte er
Vermehrte durchgänge erkannt haben und nicolas ri setzte damals noch einen drauf denn hinter diesen wänden. Sei wohl die mumie von tutanchamuns stiefmutter
Nofretete zu finden nicht wenige witterten eine sensation es gab pressekonferenzen ohne ende
zusätzliche bodenuntersuchungen eines reha spezialisten aus japan machten weitere hoffnung denn auch seine messungen ergaben hinweise darauf dass
möglicherweise zwei weitere unbekannte räumen existieren könnten
langwierige und aufwendige radler messung eines forschungsteams
im auftrag von national geographic sollten dann den endgültigen beweis liefern doch der blieb aus und das obwohl mehr als
40 stunden lang 40 1 gemacht worden sind und das in zwei verschiedenen frequenzen doch der scan
Im tal der könige schien sogar der sensation zu widersprechen das damalige forschungsteam war sich, am ende sicher
Unentdeckte kann man also hohlräume müssten eine starke reflexion liefern und die blieb aus jetzt gibt es neues futter rund um das grab von
tutanchamun ein italienisches forschungsteam von der universität turin hat jetzt wohl anomalien
angrenzend an das fahrrad gefunden und zwar zwei stück links und rechts von
tutanchamuns grabkammer das hätten drohnen bilder gezeigt mit der sie die
Grabstätte gescannt hat darauf sei eine sowohl links als auch rechts von der grabkammer eine rote fläche
zu sehen links etwas größer als rechts auch die fläche unmittelbar
Neben der kammer weise anomalien auf so der ehemalige antik minister ägyptens mam duell dabei
Wir können leider noch nicht sagen was diese anomalien bedeuten auf die frage ob es sich vielleicht tatsächlich um die
grabkammer von königin nofretete handelt sagte nur weiter während wissenschaftler
Und keine spekulanten weitere untersuchungen bräuchten zeit und könnten dann gewissheit geben doch sein begriff der anomalie
hinterlässt tatsächlich ein großes fragezeichen denn damit könnte theoretisch gesehen natürlich alles oder nichts gemein sein ein hohlraum ein loch oder
Doch eine unbekannte kammer bislang sind diese neuen ergebnisse des italienischen forschungsteams jedenfalls noch nicht in einem, wissenschaftlichen
Fachjournal zu finden, im laufe
des jahres 2018 soll dann von innen weiter
Gescannt werden und zwar mit hilfe eines bodenradar was am kit ministerium ergebnis betont an dieser stelle aber immer wieder
dass lediglich ein punkt die höchste priorität
Habe und zwar die unversehrtheit des bauwerks und erst wenn
gewissheit darüber herrsche dass es einen weiteren bislang unbekannten raum
Gibt würden bohrungen erlaubt werden dann könnte nämlich eine kamera eingeführt werden und uns den fall der fälle
Beweisfotos liefern es bleibt also weiter sehr sehr spannend was sein ergibt noch alles auftaucht erst vor kurzem gab. Es ja
aktuelle entdeckung von mumien
monumenten und einem
Hohlraum in der cheops pyramide an dieser stelle vielen dank an alle die meine aussprache
Korrigiert haben wenn ihr kein video zum thema und auch
Zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergessen nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer wieder über neue
videos informiert wenn sie erscheinen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
geheime kammer der cheops-pyramide
entdeckt ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran